The most special thing or what I
would like to see in my work that we are
doing is the effective access to power
of people who belong to regions or
zones to schemes that are generally excluded
in the country to have a greater diversity of
representation and leadership
of the country, a diversity made up of
nothing socially conscious, committed to
achieving that status, also that
it is normal for a leader of a community in
Medellín or a leader of one of the
most difficult neighborhoods in Cali to
be in the mayor's office generating programs
doing things but  In addition, providing
the mayor's office or the power schemes with that
knowledge about their territory and the
alternative solutions to
problems in their territory and being a
reference for society, so yes, I
dream that there are more many visible hands
that are the ones that are forming the  that
we are training in
definitive spaces of power and that also when they
are in those spaces of power they have
not only the best preparation but
the awareness of their historical role in
improving the living conditions
of their communities